if you were trapped 13 000 meters below
the earth's surface what would you do
you'll have to give up everything you
love in order to reach the bottom to
find answers and there's no turning back
i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
bondrew to the novel in maiden abyss
dawn of the deep soul these kids have no
idea that they will soon have to give up
everything they love in order to make
their dreams come true and they have no
clue of what it will cost them in the
process rico and reg after going through
so much in the abyss have finally teamed
up with this furball named nanichi and
they're off continuing their adventure
to find answers to their most desperate
questions down within the abyss like
where the hell is rico's mother who
wrote that note that rico found telling
her to come down here and what in the
hell is reg and where in the abyss did
he come from this is what the group
hopes to find out and they have nearly
reached the fifth layer of this
horrifying abyss and they come across
the garden of the flowers of fortitude
and it is here where they hear the most
horrifying sounds unknown echoing
screams coming across from the distance
and just then reg finally spots a cave
raider but as rhaegar goes to take a
closer look nanichi realizes that this
cave raider is in fact a member of the
terrifying umbra hands okay this is
insane these guys have already crossed
through what is basically literally hell
itself and rico has already almost died
and this time they also had nanaji who
might as well be the resident sherpa of
the abyss down here since she
practically knows this place like the
back of her paw she should have but
failed to inform the gang of the dangers
of this seemingly beautiful garden
because even though this place looks
magical there's more to it than meets
the eye this wondrous garden is
classified as especially dangerous
because of the migration of the
amaranthine deceptors which by the way
are insects that live within the fifth
to sixth layer of the abyss and
regularly use the cover of this
expensive garden to blend in with the
leaves hence the name deceptor because
these bastards will turn this garden
into a death trap against anyone who
gets too close to them they attack
humans and plant living larva inside
their flesh nanachi should have
prevented reg from closing the gap
between them and that umbra hans member
by spending more time doing
reconnaissance from afar since they
already had the tech to spy from a
distance if they had simply waited a
moment longer nanichi could have figured
out who this guy was before reggae got
spotted because the umbra hands are
members of bond roods group of cave
raiders who might as well be called his
minions because they'll do anything for
bondrewd himself which means this group
needs to take more precautions the
further down they go within the abyss
because it won't always be nature itself
that they only have to look out for it
is at this moment that nanichi realizes
just who the hell this horrifying cave
raider is and where he came from but
it's too late because this dude has just
locked eyes with our dear old rag making
his arm hair stand to attention in fear
suddenly the cave raider disappears and
basically teleports right in front of
reg prompting him to raise his
weaponized arm in defense reg now more
on guard than he's ever been asks if
that scream he heard was his doing but
the cave raider simply warns reg to pipe
down or he'll wake them this menacing
cave raider with a voice deeper than
darth vader then hands rake an old relic
that they lost back in season one rico's
blaze reap relic which is a highly
destructive large pickaxe that contains
everlasting gunpowder that functions as
basically a mini rocket launcher the
cave raider then informs reg that this
area is off limits and that they've all
been under watch for some time now
shocking nonichi and proving that who
awaits them down within the abyss is far
more powerful than they could ever
imagine nanichi warns rake to back off
but reg is too determined to find out
more about this guy who then demands to
know just what this cave raider was up
to just then rico takes out a pamphlet
containing information on just what it
is that reg is about to see and it is
truly horrifying reg then comes across
this insect hiding within the leaves all
around him in this beautiful garden
where they attack and implant their
larva inside organisms that come near
them just like this guy they keep their
victims just alive enough so that they
can continue to consume on their flesh
for even longer showing us the horrors
of what awaits this group the further
down they descend and this is just the
tip of the iceberg it is then when they
all hear a siren in the distance marking
it as a signal for this ombre hand cave
raider to get out his flamethrower and
to begin burning the entirety of the
field while rey looks on in shock as the
two other insect infested cave raiders
burn along with the flower field right
then the cave raider mentions that the
sovereign of dawn is eagerly awaiting
them all just then nanichi tells reg to
get the hell out of there and reg rushes
back to the group and they decide to
push forward going deeper down within
the abyss later the group finally
reaches the final frontier the fifth
layer also known as the sea of corpses
the last point within the abyss that
humans can return from because once they
cross this layer once they go past this
point they can never return to the
surface and the group comes across a
forward operating base in the distance
one that is bondrewd's personal research
lab and it is also the base where
nanichi was experimented on known as ido
front which also functions as a base
that holds the only entrance to the
sixth layer and it is also a place where
expert white whistle explorers use for
their last descent nanachi then says
that in order for them to get to the
sixth lair they'll likely come across
bondrood himself who is a psychopathic
legendary all-powerful mad scientist
who's willing to sacrifice anything in
order to find out the secrets of the
abyss the group then readies to enter
into what will be their final test okay
hold up here these guys are approaching
this way too casually this is ido front
the final obstacle in their way to going
further down into the abyss and this
base is also where the terrifying
bondrud the novel lives and works in
this guy is a legendary white whistle
explorer and the guy who owes and warned
us back in season 1 that this guy
according to everyone up on the surface
regularly resorts to illegal and morally
questionable means in order to get his
way as this station's top scientist
seriously this guy will do whatever it
takes if it means him becoming one step
closer to discovering the secrets of the
abyss and nanichi herself is proof that
he's experimented on humans before
turning them into actual monsters in
pursuit of science and this is the last
stop before they likely come face to
face with this monster so if i was them
i'd take a day to talk things over
because if they really want to follow
through with this they better plan this
out because bondrewd has been known to
steal relics in the past and also has a
history of stealing artifacts to further
his own gain and he's a man of knowledge
so like what do you think he'll do once
he finds out that reg is basically a
walking living breathing relic of the
abyss i'm pretty darn sure he's not
going to let him walk out of there rake
is singularly unique so far we've only
found him as the only relic that is
sentient rag his body could contain a
myriad of secrets that bondrewd would
love to exploit if he's curious enough
about him i would look into seeing if we
could get some maps of this place if
maybe we could go halfway around if
there was any way that we could go under
it because i'm pretty sure we would all
prefer to not get caught by a mad
scientist but if we insisted on going
through it i would make sure that we
armed ourselves to the teeth with
whatever makeshift weaponry we could
find because we're going to need all the
strength we can muster once we step foot
inside that sinister looking base and we
need to keep our guard way up the group
begins to make plans on how to
infiltrate the menacing base and they
make note of the fact that this place
was built on the ruins of what was once
a ruined site thousands of years ago
little do they realize that they're
being watched by someone and this
someone will change their lives forever
the group then reaches an impasse as
nanaji warns them of what's to come and
how they should choose their words
carefully because they don't know how
much bondroot and his goons know
information is power and warns them that
whatever happens to them they shouldn't
show any fear and oh how right little
nana chi is the gang then reaches a cold
dark entranceway and they are greeted by
none other than the little being that
will change their lives this little girl
who we come to find is named pruska as
her beady eyes and hunger for curiosity
counter the group with a barrage of
questions a million miles a minute but
reg's mouth remains sealed as he
remembers nanachi's warning to not give
too much away it is then here that
pruska's words usher in a wave of terror
for the group as she calls out the words
papa to a dreaded strange figure
approaching in the distance and one that
sends shivers down nanaji's spine they
are now face to face with the infamous
bondrewd the novel the sovereign of dawn
in a shocking twist bondrewd greets the
group cheerfully and congratulates
nanaji on being set free alluding to
what happened to her dear old cursed
friend who reg set free days back by
putting her out of her misery
traumatized nanichi opts to skip the
pleasantries and gets to the main point
of why they're here they want to descend
through the entrance into the sixth
layer of the abyss but bondrewd informs
them that the entrance to the sixth
layer can only be opened by the sound of
a white whistle and only the true owner
of that white whistle can activate the
doorway as the timbre of its sound
frequency must match perfectly with that
of the original owner this means that
rico's group can't continue their
journey since rico only has her mother's
white whistle and lacks one of her very
own okay white whistles are second grade
artifacts and are ones that are awarded
to only the best cave writers though i
would not include bond rude however
there's only a handful of them in
existence and if we remember technically
rico never got her own white whistle and
was given her mother's way back in the
beginning of season one the timbre that
a white whistle gives off means the
sound quality or the tone quality of a
note played on a musical instrument
because even within the same family
different instruments have varying tone
timbres this is important because this
basically means that you could have two
of the same instruments emitting the
same identical pitch at identical
volumes and they'd still produce
distinct timbres or sound colors between
the two and despite being blood related
i doubt rico can perfectly 100 match the
sound of her mother that she made on the
white whistle now there's still a ton
that we don't know about the abyss and
bondrewd's an outright filthy scumbag
but i take a shot in the dark and ask if
andrew himself could open up the portal
to the sixth layer using his white
whistle worst case he says no or makes
up some excuse as to why he can't do it
and this way we can simply head our way
back out of this creepy base and call it
a day because i know that this dead
space wearing dr isaac wannabe scientist
has got some tricks up his sleeve and i
do not want to wait around to find out
what those are rico is devastated at the
news as she clutches onto her mother's
white whistle and she remembers that
this is the same thing that beard guy
and ozin mentioned before rico's naive
young nature proves once again that life
simply won't work out because you had
good intentions and little does she
realize that her misery is only going to
get worse as her beloved friends will
die because of her soon enough bondrewd
then offers them a place to stay at this
base and mentions that pruska already
made a room for them and so with little
choice and needing time to think on
their next move the group cautiously
accepts his invitation entering further
into the eerie compound full of
fanatical white whistles who will do
anything to further their own knowledge
of the barely explored abyss pruska then
leads the group down the faded orange
hallways showing them the ins and outs
of the station and more importantly
what's on and off limits to them opening
the iron door to a barren room full of
meal rations here we also find out more
information on pruska about how she was
born down here and how she has never
been to the surface nor has she ever
seen the glory of what a true dawn looks
like although while rico plays nice with
pruska nanachi doesn't trust her for
[ __ ] and wonders what tricks bondrewd
has up his sleeve this time around and
the group prepares to head for bed but
before they pass out reg notices
something discomforting and a little
strange as he puts on his helmet the
light that usually comes on has become
fainter this time around and nanichi
having a relic similar to reg's helmet
suspects that his helmet is showing the
number of uses he has left before it is
empty or unusable this shocks rag who
thinks that this fading indicator of
light on his helmet could mean that soon
reg will run out of power since he is
after all a robot boy who relies on
energy this means that reg will need to
be careful and conserve his power
especially with how he uses his hand
incinerator weapon
she thinks that based on how his power
reserve looks like now that he may only
have three shots left on his incinerator
weapon before he runs out of power for
good later on reik and nanichi
eventually head to bed until later in
the night rico wakes up having to use
the bathroom only to realize the bed is
empty confused and alert rico then heads
out to find her friends and also a
bathroom only to come to find a bunch of
locked doors and this dark hole and her
bladder lets her know that it needs to
go okay this is too suspicious one
minute bond root is welcoming us open
arms and already having a bed made up
for everybody how nice and the next
minute everybody i know is conveniently
missing there's no way i would go back
to bed in this instance and rico needs
to assume that the worst of the worst
has happened because like i mentioned we
can't trust bondrewd for [ __ ] especially
not after what ozin from back in season
1 told us this guy values knowledge
above all else which means i wouldn't be
surprised if he was holding all of my
friends hostage right about now at the
bottom of some crazy lab liquefied in a
petri dish look the only thing that we
can do realistically speaking is to find
out where reg is and get the hell out of
here because if we can find reg then at
least we'll have a shot of being able to
help nanachi too wherever she is but in
this situation we don't have the upper
hand we're in bondroot's place we're
surrounded by his people we need to
remain calm and make it our mission to
find pruska because she'll likely have a
better idea of where everything is and
she is naive enough to help us out
without thinking too much about our
motives i would make sure pruska leads
us to some weaponry and then go towards
finding reg because honestly it makes no
sense for us to venture even into the
sixth layer if we don't have reg or
nanichi with us because one reg is our
best offense against the abyss and
nanichi is our best way in navigating
that place safely so if we can't find
either one of them there's little point
in staying down here the adventure is
over we need to go back home suddenly
something catches rico's eyes as her
focus from feeling the gaping pains of a
filled bladder shifts to a much more
enticing object the forbidden staircase
that pruska previously mentioned was off
limits thinking her friends could be up
there rico begins making her way upwards
and suddenly the wonders of the abyss
begin to work their sadistic charm over
her causing her to lose all of a sudden
her sense of direction as up is no
longer up and down is a plane unknown to
her and suddenly rico then collapses
while her ears begin to hear the faint
words of someone familiar it's pruska
right as she hovers over an injured rico
politely scolding her for her decisions
and she mentions that the fifth layer
curse takes away a person's sense of
touch and balance and this explains what
rico felt however rico mentions that all
the doors are locked which forces pruska
to check them all out and she's right
and pruska mentions that this has never
happened before little do they both
realize that there is a sinister
reasoning behind this that they'll soon
come to find out in the most horrible
ways meanwhile as the large hallways of
this base continue to echo an
ever-present sinister hum nanaiji
decides to hold a secret meeting with
her former boss and captor nanaji begins
to question who pruska is to bond rude
and he tells her that she was a failed
lab experiment which he took into race
as his own which means that pruska
thinks bondrewd is the best father in
the whole wide world and she loves him
with all of her heart this is why
bondrewd tells nanichi that his research
here is finally coming to an end and
that he wants nanichi to come back to
work for him again and so nana she
agrees under the condition that bondrewd
lets her friends reg and rico continue
their journey down towards the sixth
layer of the abyss but it is at this
moment that bondrewd realizes that he
messed up because he's already done
something bad shocking nanaji and she
runs with all her might to go save rag
greg's eyes snap open and he finds
himself strapped down and surrounded by
muttering scientists greg fidgets and
begs for his life as these monsters then
chop off his arm cutting through
mimicked bone and ligaments and rag
begins to cry out in pain suddenly
nanichi comes charging in swiping her
paws at these bastard of scientists away
from reg and she helps him escape as she
catches up with rico and pruska who also
finds out that this was all organized on
behalf of pruska's daddy the gang then
prompts pruska to get the hell out of
there as she leads them to a boat before
sending them off but unlucky for them
bondrewd is also a ruthless and skilled
hunter and tracker and he follows them
all the way down to this cave right
before reg then fires up his arm
grappling hook and ascends the duo
upward just as this gigantic stinger
head pops up to devour all of these
scientists whole okay now by the looks
of things it seems as though that they
have bond root dead to rights but here's
the thing this gigantic beast is known
as a stinger head which is a huge
seven-tailed scorpion predator that
lurks around the fifth layer containing
enough deadly poison that it can melt
flesh and bone with one sting and this
creature is not edible at all so there's
little reason to engage them in battle
unless you think you can actually win
against them but a key signal that will
let people know that they're nearby is
that a stinger head's nest has a
particular smell that the nest emits and
it's somewhat similar to dried vomit
listen this fact is important because it
means that an experienced cave raider
such as bondrood should have been able
to recognize the smell from when he
first got there and since this creature
is not edible there's nothing to be
gained from bondrewd fighting this thing
unless he thinks he can win which if
he's right means we are so screwed and
not out of the woods at all i would have
taken this opportunity to attack
bondrewd while he was distracted and use
reik's incinerator blast to take him out
if we remember reg still has about three
uses left before he runs out of energy
and i think this is one instance where
we would warrant the use of his
abilities worst case if he runs out of
juice we could just leave him down there
and let bondrewd have him another option
we leave him down there and eventually
come back with our powerful white
whistle friend ozin who we met back in
season one and we can ask her to help us
retrieve rag and with this we would have
ozen and nanichi which means that even
if reg did run out of juice we could
rely on ozen and nanichi to ascend the
abyss if we did lose reg the gang then
takes refuge behind this sandstone wall
and they contemplate their next move
hoping that this mighty creature of the
abyss will finally take out bond roode
but they're about to find out that this
mad scientist might as well be the
maiden abyss version of the terminator
because he just keeps coming back and we
see bondrewd pop out seemingly unharmed
and he comments that he knows where
nanichi is hiding a trick that nanichi
thinks he's using to peek in on her
sense of sight meaning hiding is not an
option and so the gang decides to switch
tactics hitting him hard and fast before
reinforcements come charging up to him
simultaneously from all angles and in
every way that they can with reg coming
at him hard and forcing him down within
the cold depths of the frozen water
right above the sixth layer before
suddenly repelling up backwards forcing
bondrew's human body to feel the effects
of what happens when you rapidly ascend
the abyss which caused him to experience
a slew of biophysical problems that take
hold of his body and he slowly begins to
die right before reg drops a final rock
on his body just then reinforcements
arrive along with prusko who is
absolutely heartbroken to see her father
laying dead in front of her and right
then we see the most insane thing ever
happen this guy a member of the umbra
hands rips the helmet off of bondrewd
and places it upon his head all of a
sudden this umbra hand transforms into
bondrud he's alive this shocks the whole
crew to their core and on top of that
bond druid reveals something even more
sinister he congratulates the group on
helping pruska's love for bondrew to
grow stronger and means that he can now
experiment on pruska and use her
unrequited love for him as a means for
his body to receive the blessing which
basically means that now bondrewd will
be able to sacrifice pruska and use the
love that she has towards him as a means
of receiving the blessing of the abyss a
transformation which will enable his
body to freely roam the depths of the
abyss like nanichi without dying this
was his ultimate plan all along just
like he did with nanichi and midi it was
midi's love for nanaji that caused
nanichi to receive the blessing and not
the curse of the abyss but it required
sacrifice in the form of a midi losing
her soul bondrewd then takes his leave
as the distraught gang eventually tries
to figure out how bondrewd survived and
rico suspects that he used the zoaholic
soul slave machine relic to copy his
consciousness into another person but
then nanichi thinks that he can simply
transfer his consciousness even without
the mask but that he'll have problems if
he expands his force field too much and
that the mask is just a symbol hold the
crap balls up we gotta talk about what
rico just suggested because they went
over it way too casually we gotta talk
about the zoaholic soul slave machine
relic for a second because this is one
such relic that is arguably the most
important relic out there like rico
mentioned the zoaholic allows the user
to basically transplant their mind into
other living beings spreading the
consciousness of one person through
multiple beings if i was rico i'd say
screw pruska and work on finding the
zoaholic first because this way we'll be
able to outsmart bondrewd by destroying
this relic cutting him off from his
source of power this way if we try to
kill him he won't be able to simply jump
into another body and we can finally get
rid of him for good i know pruska is an
adorable snot-looking mushroom but we
gotta let her go and get our priorities
straight if we want to have any shot of
defeating bond rude angry nanichi and
down in outer rico plot their plans to
take back pruska and save her nanachi
already knowing the layout of the base
lays out the plan for the team reg using
his robot energy absorbing body will
head down into the room that houses the
power source for the station and while
he absorbs all the energy that this
place has to offer riku and nanaichi
will buy him some time by playing nice
with ido front's bodyguards meanwhile a
lost and confused pruska finally wakes
up naked and cold on an operating table
and her daddy watches over her drawing
marks all over her body markings as to
where those slicer open all for bond
roots gain and he looks into the
innocent pure eyes of pruska and
mentions that they'll see the dawn
together if rico can get to her in time
she might be spared and the clock to
save her starts ticking elsewhere reg
reaches the power station room and not
knowing what to do clumsily takes apart
some cord wrapping to unveil some
exposed wiring and he places his hands
on it and absorbs everything that this
station has to offer and feeling all of
this newfound deadly power coursing
throughout his body just then with the
energy drained from the entire station
rico and nanaichi use this opportunity
to escape from bondrewd's guards and
this tiny fluffy fat sausage of a
creature leads them right into this
sadistic looking lab and nanachi comes
across something that she should have
never stumbled upon used cartridges
filled with crushed spines and organs of
children that bondrewd used for all of
his sick experiments cramming their
flesh inside of these cartridges and
worst of all nanaji helped him through
all of this any sensory organ that might
hamper the curse of the abyss was
chopped off from their body all to be
used towards bondrewd's goal of becoming
an indestructible cave raider who can
survive all layers within the abyss this
is what remains inside those cartridges
and what nanaji and her friend were
subjected to and that is what nanichi
helped bondrew with as his slave all
those years ago nanachi loses it and
begins breaking down crying and rico
goes to comfort her but they barely have
time to get it together when in comes
bond rude himself nanaji then angrily
accuses bondrewd of killing innocent
children for his cartridges as rico's
mouth drops open wide but bondrewd then
mentions that he assumed they were here
to create ricoh's white whistle one
belonging to rico and not her mother and
he reveals here and now to the young
group of kids the realities of what it
takes to actually make a white whistle
because in order to make one someone
else who has undying love towards rico
must sacrifice themselves in order to
create a white whistle showing just how
sadistic one needs to be in order to
become a white whistle cave raider
rico's mind is shattered suddenly
nanichi tackles rico to safety as a
massive explosion erupts in front of bon
drude it's rake and he's powered up and
ready to kick ass okay this is insane
but also a little strange if what it
takes to create a white whistle is
needing someone else who loves you so
much that they're willing to sacrifice
themselves in order to create a white
whistle is this the deep dark secret
that no one else knows about or do only
the higher levels of the cave raiders
know i'd imagine that this is something
that would have been brought up at least
once during her training back in season
one white whistles are made out of
second grade artifacts called life
reverberating stones whereby the raw
material needed to help make a whistle
as bondrewd said is a human being
basically someone needs to be willing to
sacrifice everything for rico
essentially killing themselves and then
turning into a life reverberating stone
from which rico can then use as her
white whistle now bon drude is about to
have his hands full with fighting a
roided up rag and this means that this
is the perfect opportunity for riko and
nanichi to begin scouring the entire edo
front base for more umbra hand members
because remember from last time that we
killed bond rude he has the ability to
switch his consciousness with another
member of the umbra hands this means
that bondrud is using everyone working
at his base as his slave and backup body
this way if his current body dies
there'll still be somebody else around
the base that is willing to offer up
their body to bond rude so if we take
out all the other members of the umbra
hands we might be able to have a shot of
stopping bond druid for good and ideally
along the way find pruska reg now
powered up with the energy of the entire
base in his body takes on the sovereign
of dawn and bondrewd now all powered up
from the energy of dead children in his
body battles it out with rag nanichi
then looks in pure awe as the once sweet
little robot boy she once knew unleashes
his darkest powers upon bond rude
tearing him apart and showing him who's
boss but this sadistic white whistle
cave raider knows his stuff and parries
his attacks in a series of moves
crushing rake down flat until reg begins
to let out a charged ever expanding
release of energy meanwhile rico bolts
out of there to find pruska just as she
comes across the zoaholic artifact but
all of a sudden back where reg is
nanachi realizes what he's about to do
and jumps on top of him begging him not
to do what she thinks he'll do which is
to blow up the entire base with his most
powerful weapon his big ol incinerator
but is too late as a gigantic blast is
emitted and much of the base is blown to
bits suddenly ejecting nanichi into
space when suddenly a back to normal
wreck awakens and gets her to safety
nanichi then lets out a wide-eyed grin
thinking the worst to be over but
nothing is as it seems in the abyss
because just then a henchman of bond
root tackles rhaegar down this gaping
chasm right down to the bottom where we
find all of the creatures just like
nanichi's once living friend all victims
of bond twisted experiments and suddenly
bondrewd walks into the light he's alive
as he walks past all of these creatures
he utters each and every one of their
human names indicating that he remembers
all who sacrificed their lives for his
efforts his efforts into solving the
mystery within the abyss and he's not
happy with what reg has done to his base
and it'll cost him big and so the two
get ready to battle it out one final
time okay this is insane and they are so
screwed even if reg could use his most
powerful weapon his energy beam
incinerator he's only got a few more
shots left in the tank but even if he
had unlimited shots bondrewd right now
is too fast for rake to actually hit him
now looking at bondrewd in terms of his
strengths he's pretty much
indestructible at the moment but the one
thing that we can take out is his
cartridges which again are specialized
packages made from the flesh of dead
children that he uses to sustain energy
and combat the curse of the abyss that
is his weak point which means if reg can
bridge the gap between him and bondrewd
he could effectively take out bondroot's
cartridges from close range either by
damaging it through brute force or
through some kind of sustained force of
course this would no doubt require for
him to take some punches as he gets
close to him but in reality this is his
best bet to take bondrud out if rake
doesn't use his energy beam incinerator
at all and by judging from how
overpowered bondrewd is we really only
have a few options of taking him down
reg battles it out with bondrewd but
this time his normal self is no match
and to make matters worse bondrewd
begins transforming into a creature
similar to how nanichi was transformed
with the love of someone close to him
sacrificing themselves for bond rude for
nanachi it was midi for bond rude it's
pruska and bondrewd's body begins to
expand growing claws and a bigger
stature just as he transforms into his
final form a creature now able to climb
every inch of the abyss without dying
all hope looks to be lost for our heroes
but reg has nanaji on his side as she
through the comms informs reg of the
plan to take bondrew down by evading all
of his attacks and making him use up all
of his power cartridges and reg waits
for his incinerator beam gun to charge
up doing everything that he can he
dodges all that bondrewd throws at him
until bondroot's cartridges runs out and
that's when the gang finds out that
within one of those cartridges is pruska
what a new anime crew we're back with
another mid vid review so albert tell me
what did you think of the maiden abyss
movie so honestly the movie is really
good it builds upon the mystery of the
first season but it also sets up some
questions for season two like how deep
does this abyss go or who became rico's
mother's white whistle this sets up a
lot of anticipation for the second
season what do you think of the movie
dom i'll be honest for me i didn't like
the movie too much you know the whole
point of the tv show was exploring the
abyss and in here they didn't explore
[ __ ] look i get it it's more of a
character piece exploring bond yadda
yadda i get it but exploring the abyss
was so exciting though bondrewd is a
badass however alright back to the video
news of pruska having been turned into
meat mulch shocks both reg nanichi and
even rico who in the distance crumbles
to the floor in disarray with rag's old
robot arm but reg doesn't have time for
her emotional [ __ ] as bondrewd
pounces on a now hapless reg who fires
and misses his incinerator shot all hope
seems lost but suddenly rico finally
comes to her senses and launches her big
fatty blast with reg's arm blasting and
bruising that bastard bondroot right in
between the bod as a wave of light
glosses over everything after the light
show nanachi walks up to bond root who
in his dying state mentions that he's
proud of everything that narachi has
become and they come to an understanding
right as nanichi this time around
refuses to fall for his sweet honeyed
words and she watches bondrewd finally
kick the bucket meanwhile a weeping rico
then sees something fall out of pruska's
cartridges it's a white whistle meaning
that as her last dying wish pruska
sacrificed her life to become rico's
white whistle gaining her and the gang
access to the sixth layer of the abyss
and miraculously with their mourning
period lasting less time than it takes
to cook a bag of popcorn the gang then
moves on and prepares to enter the
portal to the sixth layer and just then
they see bondrewd alive again along with
a new body this time around and like a
proud twisted sadistic psychopathic
father he bids them farewell on their
journey and they evacuate the fifth
layer and finally enter the sixth layer
of the wondrous and terrifying abyss and
if you want to join us in the seventh
layer of abyss don't forget to like
comment subscribe and check out the how
to be playlist down below